[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to game slots
2017 Year in Review we are going to be
talking about virtual reality I'm Mike
McCarty here with Jimmy thank you
Michael hi I'm AI Jimmy overall what was
this year I feel like we've been talking
for a few years about VR as far as
Wednesday's breakout year gonna be and I
think maybe last year was the year
really at home especially with the psvr
kind of wrapping the year up but well
how would you say 27 team fared for the
VR space yeah sure there were a lot of
expectations coming into the launch of
VO we had all of your headsets released
last year and I think 2017 people are
expecting it you know is it gonna go
mainstream it's not it's definitely not
mainstream yet but like all disruptive
tech you know these things take time
these take years this I would say was a
growing year for B on all the major
headsets had price drops it'd be that
much more affordable I think leading the
charge in terms of sales was psvr
they probably did the best this year
oculus rift you know went from $800 at
the beginning of the year for the bundle
down to like 600 and then recently in
October to like four yeah now it's half
the original price right yeah so like
one of the major criticisms was that all
these headsets are really expensive well
they're much more fairly priced and
affordable now in general like any kind
of exclusives that are on the near
horizon that you're looking forward to
yeah so I mean we're recording this
video before right before doom comes out
sure VFR yeah doom VFR which is a game
that's entirely built from the ground up
for VR I'm releasing on PlayStation and
the vibe looking forward to that I still
need to play you know more Skyrim VR I
know you had a chance to play a little
bit of that as well yeah and yeah so
this couple titles I'm looking forward
to yeah Michael earlier in the year we
also had resident guild 7br which is
pretty much like the flagship VR title
for PlayStation VR I would say like you
were saying psvr probably had the most
units sold this year yeah I think it's
because it's the easiest one to add and
it's right places you know original say
oh I can play this game in VR on PSP are
its easiest one to explain it's not like
I set up that they have to go through
did you get the chance to play at
resonable 7nv are much I didn't get to
play Resident Evil 7vr
but I think that I've I've listened to a
lot because John Luke I asked him a lot
of questions about what his experience
because it's crazy how well that game
adapted by not really changing much
of like its foundation and you know the
horror game that's a full-on game like
this isn't a tech demo this isn't an
on-rails shooter yeah I think it's a
real accomplishment for virtual reality
and Resident Evil 7 and psvr in
particular because like you mentioned
like the install bases there it's super
easy to setup and then here's this full
game to go along with it yeah so I think
that that was early in the year I kind
of thought of it as like the killer app
for VR as a whole not as psvr it's a
good example to go off of for future VR
games yeah we talk a lot about the
oculus and psvr Jimmy how did HTC and
valve do this year so I would say the
HTC probably lost the most momentum so
coming into 2017 if you were gonna ask
me like which PC VR headset you should
buy I would say the vibe but as of today
I would say the rift I mean I think that
the price point the $400 price point is
a great deal and like you can like find
it on sale for 350 from time to time
which is insane I think if you see that
you should jump on it I'm a big fan of
it I think the vibe
they didn't well HTC didn't really do
all that much this year they revealed
the vive trackers which will allow you
to like track things objects in VR that
aren't you know be are tracked like you
can put a tracker on like a cup or
something like that so you can see it in
VR oh so that's supposed to be rolling
you know now you know ill time will tell
if you know that actually pans out on
the consumer side of things and then
valve
you know tease their knuckle controllers
late last year and you know I was hoping
to see it this year
but we don't have a release date so the
new controllers they wrap around your
hands and they allow you to like pick
and release objects and it's like throw
a football or whatever yeah I'm so I was
looking forward to that it checks all
your fingers but we haven't had you know
heard anything about it since
and then valve also said they're working
on three full-fledged VR games for the
vive as well we haven't heard anything
about that either so it's weird like
we're looking at by the end of the year
the vibe will have fallout 4 as well in
addition to the festive seems to be
pouring a lot of resources into
obviously doom VFR which was built from
the
it's not just the doom 2016 or we
mentioned Skyrim which is obviously
gonna keep coming out in every platform
ever for the rest of our life but when
you think about like the third-party
support coming in like Bethesda to help
out VR do you think it's pretty
promising overall yeah so I had a chance
to sit down and speak with Jason Rubin
who is like the head of content and
oculus yeah and I asked him about like
triple-a development and stuff like that
you know are they coming and he was
mentioning that you know a lot of them
are already here like as mentioned but
does is here you know
respawn is jumping on board making like
maybe a titanfall of the arch area and
maybe like the last whole there's the
last company to really hold out as maybe
like EA even though they kind of made
that Star Wars the other thing as well
so maybe like Activision so and he was
saying that a lot of them are jumping on
board the sales of the headsets are are
much greater now like I think there was
reports that PlayStation VR has sold
over 1.5 million headsets so I think a
lot of those big triple-a companies are
waiting for the market to mature a
little bit more and they're starting to
jump on board now I think do you think
like this year that we are overall
gained momentum Michael or do you think
this was kind of stagnate
I don't think I would say stagnant
especially with the with what psvr
was able to do I think that maybe my
expectations were a little different
because of what all the technologies you
saw earlier in the year like when we
went to CES in January we saw a lot of
like dope technology but that you know
those things take time
yeah and I guess my expectations weren't
exactly aligned talking back to Resident
Evil 7 when that hit in January I was
like okay what's the next thing and it
was kind of waiting wait wait wait wait
wait and then now in the back end of the
year and December we have doom VFR and
fallout for VR and we just got Skyrim
too so that's like whoa there's like
three incredible games right but in
between those kind of like you know
there's
yeah yeah I think that there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of expectations
for Triple A games but it's important to
to understand that like VR is relatively
new and it has some challenges like you
know developers have to figure out how
to like move players with the world
without making them sick and things like
that yeah yeah and great games take
years to make often and you know VR
hasn't been around that long so you know
let it turn the corner a little bit and
see where it goes yeah also this
conversation has been far too civil for
my taste so I'm gonna make it a
competition what VR platform do you
think one 2017 if you can single one out
so I would probably say that the rift
had a good maybe not a great year okay
but if I had to award a winner it would
definitely go to psvr
you know rumors if they sold 1.5 million
units they had a great start with
resident evil in the middle of the year
that released Farpoint with the aim
controller and then they're releasing
you know they're getting doom at the end
of the year that recently had Skyrim
dooms gonna take advantage of that new
name controller which is really cool no
fallout 4 right at least they haven't
announced that yeah I think that is
because I want to say if I had a guess
it's because so that's exclusive to the
vibe I think if I had to say why is
because it's just more graphic than
ending and I'm a VR in do you have to
run at like 90 Hertz 90 frames per
second Skyrim there's a more dated game
exactly so it's it's easier to do that
with scanning hey Michael what's your
take do you think one I would also say
PlayStation VR I think this is because
it's an example of you know you don't
need super high graphical fidelity for a
VR platform to succeed yeah it's nice to
have like we've seen on vibe and oculus
but what you need is accessibility and
an install base so for the PC ones
obviously you need a computer that is
equipped with like decent hardware yeah
but with psvr you just need a
PlayStation 4 and you know it's not the
it's not the best doing the tracking is
done through the PlayStation camera
which is doesn't give you full 360
motion tracking and it's not the most
accurate move controller's still need
like joysticks yeah yeah but what it
shows is that you know if if your price
correctly if you're accessible then
you'll succeed and if you have the
software to go along with it like a
Resident Evil 7 or Skyrim VR and far
point which is something fresh and new
then you can succeed in the VR space and
I think they displayed that this year in
2017 and but I do expect five and oculus
rift to kind of take a step forward for
the next year
sure yeah overall a steady pace for VR
between really good third-party support
more accessibility some better price
drops not a bad year for VR so here's
hoping continues 2018 we're also going
to be talking about pc nintendo ps4 and
xboxone here at GameSpot 2017 Year in
Review
so we'll see you then
[Music]